welcome to today's live broadcast
portable and easy presented by Christian
overtone our PhD and Cedric Mueller PhD
we are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by t can t can is a
leading global provider of laboratory
instruments and solutions in
biopharmaceuticals forensics and
clinical Diagnostics the company
specializes in the development
production and distribution of automated
workflow solutions for laboratories in
the life sciences sector its clients
include pharmaceutical and biotechnology
company university research departments
forensic and diagnostic labs as an
original equipment manufacturer OEM
taken is also leader in developing and
manufacturing OAM instruments and
components that are then distributed by
partner companies to learn more about
keikain please visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor your moderator
for today's event this webinar has been
approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the CD button at
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits before
we begin I would like to remind everyone
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
also please notice that you will be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge the window just click
on the screen icon located on the lower
right and finally if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button to let us know
you're having a problem thank you
now I'd like to introduce dr. Oberg
honor and dr. ruler
dr. over Donner is a product manager at
Chicken Austria he studies molecular
biology at the University of Salzburg
with strong focus on cell and tumor
biology dr. over gonner began working
for T Ken in 2005 as an external
scientific consultant and joined the
company permanently in 2006 as an
application specialist
the product manager focuses on the
company's multimode microplate reader
portfolio dr. Mueller and his smartest
co-founders Sophie Kane are our young
life sciences and health PhD graduates
from the ethic on bacteriology
laboratory directed by professor patrick
place yet where they studied the
antibiotic resistance mechanisms of
Pseudomonas original fest
since 2014 their company has provided
its expertise in microbiology and
molecular biology to help its clients
accelerate their research projects
please join me in welcoming dr. over
Donner and dr. Mueller I will now turn
the presentation over to them so thank
you for that nice introduction and a
warm welcome and hello to the audience
over from my side um what can you expect
from that educational webinar today very
briefly spoken it will be divided in two
parts in the first part I will introduce
Tekin to a solution to easily establish
lifestyle analyzers in the lab without
blowing your budget and then I will also
give you an review of what we have done
on lifestyle analysis from an
application perspective this will
include how to automate long term cell
viability cytotoxicity and apoptosis
assessment I will talk about how to
automatically monitor cell migration and
how to perform monochrome ality
verification with the systems integrated
imaging modules I will explain how to
normalize signals from cells to the cell
mass per well using confluence
assessment and I will talk about the
importance of Holwell analyzes
inflorescence Bottom readout then in the
second part My dear co-speaker Cedric I
will talk about his experience
with our solution and share all the
exciting methods he established on
lifestyle analyzes with bacterial and
eukaryotic cells so biology is certainly
always about investigating processes of
life so everybody of you will know and
I'm sure has already experienced that
SEM sells in an appropriate window of
time for example to investigate compound
mediating hai toh toxic effects that can
be extremely challenging because you're
first of all needs to keep yourself
healthy during the whole investigational
period you need to choose the right sen
method that allows you to perform
real-time and lifecell analyzes and
those methods should certainly produce
high-quality and reputable results then
you need to acquire all the data
constantly over time and you should not
lose any data in between so the very
well-known overnight gaps in a kinetic
measurement can be really critical and
you can lose important information
unfortunately the time courses are
relatively long so more than 24 hours is
standard up to several days is necessary
to investigate biological processes and
as always the whole workflow the whole
procedure needs to be relatively cheap
and should have also a minimum in manual
inputs of course so basically two
solutions or two approaches are well
known the one is what I did during my
PhD study sleeping in the lab getting up
every hour and
acquiring data points to get a full data
set over several days all you simply do
it with a robotic system but then budget
should not be any issue in your lap this
now totally changed with Tekin solution
for cost-efficient lifestyle analyzes
which is the stock multimode reader the
spot multimode reader is a system that
is fully modular upgradeable and it
includes all important high-end
detection measurement modes fluorescence
absorbance luminous with alpha screen
and so on but more excitingly it
includes also features that support
lifestyle analyzes and this is what I
will explain to you in more detail in
the next couple of slides so the first
element that we incorporated in the
system is environmental control we need
to keep the cells healthy during the
analytical experimental experimental
criteria and the first element is the
temperature control for temperature
control we made sure to isolate the
plate transport chamber from the optics
in the system to guarantee the best
possible temperature distribution in the
system that allows us to specify across
plate uniformity of plus minus 0.5
degree Celsius we use a pop heating oil
to avoid condensation on platelets and
most excitingly we have the so-called t
cool module which is the first
air-conditioned for a multimode reader
and this enables us to keep a stable
temperature between 80 and 42 degrees
over time and this of course has a lot
of important and interesting effects but
one example is that you can perfect
handle now non-mammalian cells which has
a temperature optimum far below 37
degrees for instance insect cells belong
to this group the second important
element when it comes up to
environmental control implemented in the
reader is gas control so we can control
the co2 and o2 level inside the plate
transport chamber very accurately and in
a very broad range it's all fully
integrated in the system and everything
is fully controllable via the spark
control software which is the reader
control software system we can even lock
co2 and o2 data over time so that you
always have two full control what is
going on inside the system notably Oh
two can be regulated down to 0.1 percent
and we can keep the hypoxic conditions
then between 0.1 and 0.6 percent over
time and this enables us to really
provide a system to do a physiologic
relevant studies even under highly
hypoxic conditions the third element and
that is something that is a patent tech
patent pending technology from chicken
is the humidity capsule so we invented a
cassette a metal castle that
incorporates a moat that can be filled
with United Water and in this castle you
can put them every possible microplate
in SLS format and by closing that
cassette the atmosphere inside the
castle will be passively humidified by
the evaporation of the view nice water
and this will then avoid the evaporation
of the liquid in the sample well
certainly this does only function
together with deacons unit lit lifting
system because for measurement and
for other actions you need to remove the
lid of the humidity castle and for this
we invented an integrated lip lifting
system so the fat can be and real it
micro play inside the reader not only
the humidity captured but also every
other possible microplate lick you
simply need to stick a magnetic pad on
it and the lid lifter will be able to
handle also the plastic tray this
exciting feature is accomplished with
some other features that we all are put
in the group and called smart automation
that is first of all of the Spencer
module that is equipped with the
built-in reagent heater Inspira but also
software features the kinetic
conditioning feature that allows us to
perform actions as soon as a certain
value is reached inside a control well a
very exciting feature for kinetic
measurements and the open kinetic
feature which allows users to pause and
resume kinetic experiments which
simplifies our mighty user operations so
these features the littlest thing the
dispenser module the software features
allow us to smartly automate the
workflow and that does not mean that the
workflow or that we can increase the
throughput with this but we minimize the
manual inputs and make it much more
convenient to do long-term kinetic as
our measurements especially wizard
another element that is important for
lifestyle analysis is the integrated
cell imaging modules in the spark reader
it's a 4x bright field based imaging
module cost-efficient but very easy to
use solution you can use it for cell
counting and viability checks of
suspension cells Kryptonite cells in
slide or you can measure the confluence
level and take images in bright field
from adherent cells
microplate well we also offer a life
here which is the kind of microbe
microscope mode
integrated in our software finally when
we talk about cell based assays and long
term in vitro studies perform inside the
reader we need to talk about
fluorescence bottom readouts which is
the most important measurement mode for
cell based assays in general and here we
provide several elements that help to
push the performance of your essay this
is first of all our recently launched
Tekin microplate dedicated for
fluorescence button measurements in 96
and 384 well format which was optimized
and tested together with a spark
multimode reader but also software
features helped us to improve the
quality of your data for us to bottom
read out this is the very interesting
function called optimal read that allows
a whole well analyzes after microplate
well and i will show you some exciting
data as well at the very end of my
presentation
but basically this feature allows to
record the signal from each and every
cell inside a well no matter what the
plate format is so even in 84 well or a
24 well plate can be analyzed fully
analyzed with houses we also offer set
optimization for fluorescence button
readout that means we can optimize the
set focus for fluorescence readings
which makes the system very sensitive
for cell based assays and we have a
feature that we call high definition
well area scanning this is a feature
that allows us to create a low
resolution fluorescence image of the
entire microplate well with a 100 per
100 measurement pattern but here we
don't use a camera system we use our
normal lewis to bottom readout
so honestly this takes some time and
this of course our route just a
low-resolution image of your cells
inside the world but still can give you
an idea what it what is what is
happening so enough with the technical
details are on the on the reader itself
let's talk about what you can do with
the system and here I want to start with
with a with a collaboration that we did
together with kromega and here in that
study we described a method for
automatic genetic monitoring of cell
viability cytotoxicity and apoptosis and
what we used is other kids from
premedia a design for real-time
analyzers which is the real-time low
effort to detect viability the size of
the screen si to detect cytotoxicity and
the caspase clo'es a to detect above
doses we cultivated k562 cells for over
72 hours inside the reader of course
using all the features I just explained
humidity care set temperature control
co2 control and investigated viability
size of toxicity and apoptosis all the
time for the real-time flow and the
cytotoxicity green s and you just add
the religions at the very beginning and
we left the lid of the plate on the
plate for over 72 hours and just did
periodically the respective measurements
with our reader so luminescence and
fluorescence measurements focus pays
three seven measurements we needed to
inject the caspase-3 reagent and this we
did automatically with our injectors we
pre want a real chance and then at
certain intervals injected
space 3/7 real chant we intubated 30
minutes inside the reader and then
measured the luminescence so also this
se was fully automated without any
manual input needed and certainly this
was just possible because we have too
little if the system that allows us to
unlit the plate in check something and
then relive it again the researchers at
prom [ __ ] they also did a second
experiment where they try to investigate
the potential of the kinetic
conditioning function in here they use a
sight toxicity threshold for an
automatic caspase-3 7 injection and if
you will find out when you study that
tapering more detail that also perfectly
worked out so at the end of the day we
are concluded that using just the onset
of cytotoxicity as a matter of apoptosis
it is more difficult to correctly
identify the apoptosis reduction window
for a specific drug and/or dosage and
that potentially leads to the incorrect
mode of action being assigned so it's
always very important to study all that
markers over time without loss of data
and the next study awana riff you on is
very similar to the first one it's all
it's again about measuring metabolic
markers in cells over long periods in
time but in this case we work together
with researchers of the University of
Heidelberg and the company called promo
cell which provides s is very similar to
those of promising and we investigated
the differentiation of human mesenchymal
stem cells we use ready-to-use
differentiation media and monitored then
over 60 hours differentiation to
adipocytes countryside near
sides and osteocytes and during
differentiation we measured the cell
viability constantly with a fluorometric
cell viability keep based on registering
but in addition we also measured
cytotoxicity by a' LDH and ATP levels
using a bioluminescent cell by viability
kit from chromosome
what we found is that the cell counting
and plating and culturing of stem cells
for several days with the spark worked
out fine yes you understood it correctly
cell counting and plating because those
researchers of the University of
Heidelberg they used to counting to
count the cells but then they also
wondered if they could inject them with
our injector system so if they could be
plated for culturing and that worked out
also fine so it was every everything was
very sterile and the cells perfectly
grew after injection inside the reader
we then monitor the differentiation over
60 hours and measured viability and here
we found that residue really was
non-toxic to sensors but a very
sensitive approach and early after
induction of the differentiation towards
a deeper site we found a significant
elevation of bhaiyya of metabolism and
ATP content in contrast the osteogenic
the counter genic and the neurogenic
differentiation significantly reduces
the metabolic activity of MSC
the next two studies or better three
studies are all related to the imaging
function of the spark reader in a first
study we wanted to investigate the
potential of the system to monitor cell
migration for this we observed the
migration potential of two human biliary
tract cancer cells one was reported to
be 2 - no - not migrate at all and the
other was reported to show migration
properties and we simply wanted to prove
it again we did this together with the
collaboration partner at the private
medical university of salzburg and we
use the radial cell migration SI r
together with our system this essay is
very it's a very nice thing because it
creates a cell-free area in the middle
of a fully continent well and you can
perfectly then monitor this Calvary area
for cell migration over time to stop
cell proliferation we change to FES
screen media and then observed the gap
closure either manually with the
microscope so that means taking the
plate out every hour taking the image
manually and then do it which analyzes
manually and this we compared certainly
with the automated approach in our
reader where we used again humidity
Cassatt the gas control temperature for
the whole experimental period and image
the center of the well with our imaging
function and use the inverse confluence
value to block migration and as you see
the results are perfectly comparable the
automated approach to the manual
approach but notably ah with the manual
approach you lose a lot of data points
in an overnight gap whereas with the spa
you comes can constantly measure the
repopulation of the selfie area
and don't lose any data points at all in
the second experiment that is explained
in that note we show that the confluence
level perfectly correlates with the ATP
level in the same well and this leads me
to the next topic because you can use
the confluent estimation of the
confluence assessment in our system to
normalize on cell mass we described this
effect or this potential in by applet in
a technical note if you can download on
our homepage certainly and we show that
GFP and confluence signal perfectly
tolerate here we showed between 10 and
60% but we also proved that between 10
and 90% with other essays like the BCA
essay or like really key measurements so
this clearly shows that just by
measuring the confluence level of the
whole well using the spark that can be
used to normalize on every possible exit
signal coming from the same cells in the
world and what you skip is of course an
additional essay you save reagents and
money and that is very convenient and
very helpful in an overall workflow the
last arm application that is on imaging
is very quickly explained we wanted to
test the potential of the reader for
semi-auto for monochrome LED
verification what we found basically is
that yes it works you can automatically
record the images as the system can make
Holwell images you can then after a
couple of days easily crack back to find
single cells in a well so the image
resolution the image quality is good
enough to also support this kind of
application certainly it's something in
between the manual approach
and a dedicated system for clonality
verifications like the CSI oMG the last
application note or the last study our
researchers here at you can did I want
to explain to you is about fluorescence
bottom readouts in general and here we
show the importance of the optimal read
function if you can see on the very top
image
these are fiberglass and they do not
grow homogeneously an 84 well plate they
tend to grow from the middle and
certainly if you just measure that part
in the middle you get a wrong result
that is misleading and we showed in that
application note that in 84 but also in
96 well plates the CV of your signal
dramatically drops as soon as you use
optimal read instead of singly and that
of course directly correlates with with
a very high well to Val uniformity and
an excellent sensitivity for cell based
assays as soon as you make sure to
analyze the whole well area and not just
a small part in the middle good so
finalizing my first part I will once I
want to give you some take-home messages
so first of all modern multimode readers
offer more venturous absorbance versus
and luminescence they enable for
automated lifestyle analyzes and this is
really a cheaper let's say an more cost
efficient approach than investing in
high-end robotic systems or high-end
lifestyle imaging systems and of course
it's better than staying in in the lab
for the whole night in addition to
well-established function such as
heating gas control the limit
the spot is equipped with some unique
features including humidity control
instrument cooling lake handling and
this allows to simultaneously maximize
data quality and minimize hands on time
we could show that in several
collaborative studies we could show that
how that monitoring biological processes
is very important to get out the right
results so by doing this with the spot
you can save time money and especially
it's much more conveniently easy to
establish and cost-efficient procedures
for imaging based cell migration and
monochrome relative education can be
achieved using the SPARC I think that
clearly came out and an important
message again at the end bottom reading
its standard for every multimode reader
but just special software features that
allow you to analyze the whole well
we'll give you rapid usable results with
a good relative L variability and
thereby offering a perfect and excellent
sensitivity of the system if you are now
curious and you want to know more about
the SPARC and about other applications
that our scientists and our
collaborations party did with the system
just visit our home page and with this
I'm really happy to hand over to my
co-speaker Cedric thank you well hello
so before starting I would like to thank
you Christian for introducing me and for
giving me the opportunity to to present
how company names Maltese so my speech
will be divided in two parts in the
first part I will introduce to you how
company and its capabilities and in the
second part I will present you some of
our services
where we analyze bacterial cells live
bacterial cells and how they can reader
improve our capabilities so small this
is a contract research organization
created three years ago and we are
specialized in the fields of
microbiology and molecular biology and
we provide customized services to our
customers to increase the research
capability for these peoples are small
tees with the River scientific expertise
combined with innovating tools in order
to accelerate your research programs as
you can see a small piece is located in
in business song it's located in the
east of France next to switch the lung
around one hour by car and we are
located near the hospital and the
Faculty of Medicine to have a very
important work network and in
collaboration so to provide high quality
services and to guarantee her result we
have acquired on our own financial
resources a fully equipped biosafety
level 2 laboratory and thanks to this
investment how company as a remarkable
capacity to adapt and a total
independence regarding the team how
staff has a successful academic
background and many year of expertise in
microbiology molecular biology cellular
biology Nansha biotic resistance so to
introduce you how team the team is made
of three PhD holders including the two
founders Oh dr. Sophie Jenna and myself
the team is composed also of one
engineer and one apprentice and smartest
benefit from the advice of Professor
Patrick pleasure which is a very
international
known microbial microbiologist so
relying on our research abilities we
developed our activity according to an
interconnected mixed economic model
which enabled us to set up a diversified
and innovative toolbox so as you can see
on this figure smartest team focuses on
developing innovating biological tools
in order to improve our service offer
and in this way Malthus is able to
collaborate with a new customer who have
most often nu-metal requirement and so
it involves the development of new tools
and at smartest we operate globally in
the ADI projects or in the research
process by offering unique customized
services in microbiology and molecular
biology specifically designed from the
request of Augustana and I will try
after to show you some of these services
but before to give you an overview of
our capabilities I'm going to introduce
firstly how a microbiology call tools so
they are divided in five groups the
first one include all the meter and all
the methods to characterize
microorganisms so for instance as multis
we're able to identify all bacteria used
and more by using from kilometer to
next-generation sequencing technologies
then when microorganism are identified
were able to characterize some of the
properties such as a growth rate of the
Hanseatic resistance phenotype or the
capability to produce iran's factors we
can also discriminate several
microorganisms by using a generating
method such as a pistol gel
electrophoresis MLV a method
secondly we have developed specific
tools to customize the genome of
gram-negative bacteria so we can propose
to delet specifically a gene or to
replace it by another one without
leaving any additional DNA or resistant
gases but I'll give you an example of
what we do with this - later in the
presentation
thirdly we have developed specific tools
and methods to study the skin mucosal
and this method allowing us now to be
the only company in Europe which is
capable of studying the skin microbiome
directly on LC volunteers for three
several tools has been developed whether
with how much I can adapt to a specific
compound either at the molecular level
by measuring gene expression or at the
phenotype level by measuring resistance
here finally eukaryotic cell models for
caldo to evaluate the bacterial adhesion
invasion and cytotoxic properties to
analyze the cellular response to
infections and finally to screen
compound for the unti effective
properties in eukaryotic infection
models regarding our molecular
biological tools now the other I did
into three groups the first one pulls a
method to prepare nucleic acids from
different sources such as blood cells
pled guilty and so on the second one
regroups method to quantify gene
expression by using QPR Shu PC and also
a new parameter named a lot easier we
are also able to do broadening
experiment or in vitro transcription
experiment the
one is a cloning vector construction
tools in order to construct expression
vector for application in either
prokaryotic and eukaryotic systems but I
think to better understand how of what
we are able to do as Melissa I think the
best is to switch on the second part of
my speech and to speak about live
bacterial cell analysis so live
bacterial cell analysis as you know is a
coral research tool for for researcher
and also for our customers so we have
set up several clinical methods to
characterize new and infective compounds
so I'm going to present you three of
them require of called the use of the
tickler
so for those who do not know to colonize
and initiate infections bacteria must
adhere to the old cells to do this they
use current halogen such as TV on thin
VA that you can see on our Timothy Q and
this period umbria our hair like hair
like structures that interact with
specific earth receptors located at the
cell surface for instance this mechanism
is well described for the addition of
hydrant and invasive equally strains
into the final section of the small
intestine of patients suffering of Crohn
disease but the addition phenomenon can
be prevented by using compound able to
interact specifically with battery on
halogens in a competitive manner and to
assess the bacterial in addition
properties of anti-infective compound we
have carried out specific methods the
first method is a ninja tro adhesion
assay perform from eukaryotic cell
cultures so briefly we cultivate
epithelial cells to 100,000 compounds of
course depending on the type of
infection of this is you want to
study we adapt the cell models for
instance if I go if I came back to the
current decision for this disease we for
this pathology we are going to use in
intestinal cells so when cells are to
100% confirmed they are infected with
selected battle strength with a specific
range for 10 to 100 battles helper
eukaryotic cells and after 2 hour of
infections eukaryotic and bacterial cell
are stained with dirty and specific
antibody specific antibodies conjugated
to Alexa fluor as respectively and the
bacterial adhesion is acid by
fluorescence measurements so when we
carried out this method for the first
time two years ago the fluorescence was
measuring by using an investment
microscope equipped with a specific
camera and now we use the taken reader
and I'm going to show you how taken
reader as improve how efficacy so as you
can see on this on this picture this is
the result obtained with the microscope
so eukaryotic cells nucleus are colored
in blue and bacteria appear in green if
you look at the picture from the left to
the right you can observe the impact of
different compounds on bacterial
adhesion on the positive control on the
left without molecule without a wanker
when bacteria are cultivated without
molecule you cannot have a strong
adhesion but if you look at the three
other picture each of the three
different compound tested here has a
different effect to prevent bacterial
vision so the advantage of the
microscope as you can see is the
visualization of the ad agency dominance
but there are a lot of disadvantages
first pictures capture is very long
because we must take between four to six
picture per well in order to have a good
overview of each one
once pictures are taken we must measure
by using the microscope software which
color its surface areas so the black one
the blue one and the green one in order
to make a ratio and to quantify the
adhesion phenomenon of each strain and
therefore the impact of each state speed
molecule so to give you an idea before
using the calendar we need about two
days to a place to quantify the adhesion
phenomenom of bacteria on eukaryotic
cells but now if we use the technology
to measure the fluorescence first of all
the fluorescence is not 0 automatically
and the device provides us data directly
under excel tabular form and the
acquisition time is reduced one hour per
plane and so if you look at the result
corresponding to the previous picture
you obtain directly the percentage of
addition for each condition and so for
instance of the positive control you can
observe that the percentage of hydrogen
is around 75% and with the there is an
effect with the last compound we have no
illusions indicating that the compound
at the good effect to prevent bacterial
additions so thank you taken for this
for say we have a win a lot of time the
only program is that we have no
visualization of the adhesion phenomenon
as for the microscope measurement the
second services
the second method I want to talk to you
is a is a method developed to assess the
battle evasion
in addition to Santi of unsent active
compound and this method is called an
aggregation okay the objective is to
measure how compound is able to interact
with hydrogen of bacteria this method is
easy to set up
because you just need to make bacterial
cultures with our without the Selective
molecule and talkative to cultivate both
and they're gentle agitation and to
visualize the aggregation phenomenon the
aggregation feminum so as for the in
vitro addition I say the vibration can
be done either by using the microscope
or by using the technology so first of
all if you visualize the addition with
the microscope on this picture you can
see a result result of thing on the left
when bacteria are cultivated without
compound you can observe the quasi plain
gray image but if you had a molecule
which is capable of interacting
specifically with Bachelor editing you
can observe bacterial aggregation
network represented by your less
homogeneous great picture the unique
advantage of using the microscope is the
focus cave from 10 to 400 so you can
very look specifically on a spit on on
the targeted point into the world but
this is clearly not adapted to this
experiment because you must incubate
your plate in a separate incubator and
so you must stop the bacterial growth to
take the picture because this
aggregation assay is perform during
fibrous continuously while when you use
the technology and of course the camera
included you can incubate your plate
directly into the incubation chamber and
so your picture are taken automatically
are taken automatically and so you can
reduce the experiment time and the curve
and of course we have plenty of point
leading to a better a a better view of
the aggregation phenomena bother with
this device you are always taken at the
same point into the wealth and so you
have really really really a better view
of the aggregation
aggregation
phenomenal the only one small problem
will get the kalidahs of this fog this
method is that you don't have a focus
scale and so sometimes when aggregates
are too small it's difficult to well
observe them to follow I would like to
show you some not a method but a
technique we have Anna church we have
developed expensive in order to to
reproduce and to monitor in real time
bacterial infection to do this eternal
kiss as I say we are able to to
customize the bacterial gram-negative
the genome and we have construct
gram-negative bio luminescent bacteria
they can be used for in vivo imaging
including in deep infection of mice so
warm so to do this by using how
molecular biology tool we have
constructed our gram-negative film
innocence bacteria and the advantage of
this luminescent strength that our these
trends can be constructed directly from
your own strength the luminescent is
sufficient to monitor infection in life
and so to assess the drug difficulty and
since active molecules in real time and
finally because you don't have to
sacrifice your honey most in order to
measure the infection as a bacterial
infection you can reduce the number for
your ng hostage so I'm going to to show
you how we have developed these tools so
to construct this bioluminescence
bacteria we have developed a specific
plasmid containing a very bright photo
reduce from innocence looks open from
the original placement described
actually a are in 2005 from this
construction we have clone different
promoter such as pellet promoter protect
promoters downstream the looks of France
in order to overexpress constitutive
ariza Luke's operand and to select the
writers construction we have muslims
illumination and correlated
discrimination with the backer work
schedule so to do this we have used the
taken reader in two modes simultaneously
the first one is was luminescence model
so you have the characteristic use from
this one and the second one is the
absorb Aultman by using these two
properties we were able to measure
simultaneously the luminescence of our
construction and also the growth rate of
our strengths so as you can see on there
on this glass we have obtained for
construction with which are able to
produce different level of luminescence
and as you can see there is no
correlation with the grocery so we are
selected as a writer
so here the orange one and we have
introduced it directly into the
chromosome of our selective strengths
and to do this we have used a homologous
recombination technique leading to the
accurate modification of a targeted
sequence direct into the bacterial into
the virtual chromosome so as you can see
on the Left we have represented a sham
at each of the wild-type chromosome and
thanks our tools we were able to
introduce specifically between gene a
and gene be the loops operon and the
most powerful promoter clone downstream
the operon and this lead us to have a
bioluminescent bacteria which are
usually used in in vivo infection models
so I hope that this presentation has
given you a good overview of the
possibility that Mattox offer to
increase your R&D capacity and
especially to perform battle farinelli
I hope too that this presentation gives
you a good overview of what in
particular can do to improve your your
bacterial analysis and no Christian and
me are afraid to to answer your specific
question
thank you doctor Oprah Donner and dr.
Mueller for your informative
presentations it is time for Q&A if you
have a question you'd like to ask dr.
over Donner and dr. Mueller please do so
now just click on the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window and type your question into the
box it appears on your screen and click
on the send button or answer as many of
your questions as we have time for any
questions we do not have time for will
be addressed after the presentation so
our first question is does tea can also
offer dedicated microplates for imaging
and this one is for dr. Robert honor oh
yeah thank you that's a very good
question actually
um and I need to answer it with yes and
no so taking bath not offer real
dedicated imaging plates with
psychological button or even quad button
but we also place that can be perfectly
used in conjunction with our imaging
module as it is a cost-efficient imaging
module we offer cell plates very
standard plasma treated PS plates that
perfectly work out for our imaging
system and gives a really a low
background in confluence so yes we offer
imaging for SPARC imaging module but not
for other uses next one is for you to
doctor over Donner do you offer plates
with different coatings um no all of our
cell plates a plasma treated so we do
not offer any special or surface
coatings for four for four barriers in
vitro systems just standard cell culture
plates and coach printing plate okay
next for you to disappear Kent software
from monoclonal anything of all wells
measured at a certain point in time um
yes so that question I need to answer
with no because we don't really have a
dedicated software solution for mono
clonality verification as I tried to
explain
we have we can offer a semi-automated
approach that means we can perfectly
record and archive the images
automatically but the whole analysis
process must must be done manually but
we save the images in a convenient way
so that allows you to click through all
the images very conveniently but there
is no overview about the whole blade per
day thank you doctor over Donner to see
optimal read function also health in 384
well plates um
again a very good question and which
again around me to answer with no
because the beam diameter of spark
system is already optimized for 384 well
plates so you can be sure to cover
almost the whole area of the 384 well
plate it becomes the optimal reach
function becomes more and more important
the lower the well density get so in a
fix well played I would say it's really
a must and but it still is a significant
improvement also in 96 well plate so
everything between one well and 96 well
optimal read really helps to get a
better overall result in this next one
is for you to have you also compared
signal normalization with confluence to
signal normalization with protein
quantification
yes we tried to or we compared the
confidence normalization to normal
protein quantification and normalization
done with protein quantification and we
use the BCA SS for this so we have that
data but not published in an application
note can provide it certainly to the
other customs we're almost out of time
this will have to be our last question
doctor over dawn Arcadia system be used
in plant research like in tobacco cell
lines
yes principal that's really a strength
of of the stock reader as the system
includes the only air-conditioner data
for a multimode reader we can adjust any
target temperature between eighteen and
forty two and that especially enables
the system for non mammalian cell
cultures like plant cells like there's
kind of microorganisms whatever so
that's that's the key strength of the
system yes you can use it for tobacco
plant research as well great I would
like to once again thank dr. over Donner
and dr. Mueller for their presentation
do you have any final comments thank no
I'm really happy I was really happy to
talk to you today and and would like to
thank in the name of deacon well thank
you once again I would also like to
thank our sponsor taken for making
today's educational webcast possible
this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the C e button at the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credits before we go I want
to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through December 22nd 2017
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye